how many people are alive that remember
World War II not many and the same
perhaps applies to the threat of nuclear
war yeah I mean there are enough nuclear
bombs pointed at uh United States to
make the rubel the radioactive Revel
bounce many
times there's two major Wars going on
right now so you talked about the threat
of AGI quite a bit but now as we sit
here with the intensity of conflict
going on do you worry about nuclear
war I think we shouldn't discount the
possibility of nuclear war um it is a
civilizational
threat
um right now I could be wrong but I
think the the current probability of
nuclear war is quite low um but there
are a lot of nukes pointed at us so and
we a lot of nukes pointed at other
people they're still there nobody's put
their uh their guns
away the missiles are still in the silos
and uh the leaders don't seem to be the
ones with the nukes talking to each
other no there are Wars which are tragic
and difficult on a on a local basis and
then there are Wars which are
civilization ending or has that
potential obviously Global Therman
nuclear warfare has high potential to
end civilization
perhaps permanently but certainly you
know to
severely uh wound and and perhaps
uh set back uh human progress by you
know to the Stone Age or something I
don't know pretty
bad
um probably scientists and Engineers
won't be super popular after that as
well they're like you got us into this
mess MH so generally I think we we
obviously want to prioritize
civilizational risks over things that
are um painful and tragic on on a local
level but not
civilizational